huh
what's going on Rebecca
no I just been having a bit of weird
days
are we up all night
kind of yeah
it's a Friday morning
early it's all right I have no idea
sorry hello
what's going on in your head what are
you thinking
I don't know
are you thinking
I can really bring this thing I really
don't want to be making
I don't know
you don't know what
I don't want things to be like that's
right
you think talking to a therapist would
be something you want to do so yeah I
think like
a couple of therapists have offered you
yeah
I don't know like a proper like
I don't know
because there's something going on in
your head something you went through
when you were young or something
with your brother with your dad with
your who knows who it's all about stuff
I mean whatever
you always feel that sort of thing if
you don't talk about it it's gonna have
power over here
life
it's so very complicated to talk about
it so I don't have a confidential I just
don't know if anyone sounds quiet no I'm
not a professional but I could hook you
up with somebody who is but
I just think
more than anyone I think I've ever met I
see so much potential in you and yet
you're so stuck you're more you're more
stuck than anyone I've ever seen
and you're going to be dead eventually
you do another frontal overdose
without somebody with Narcan seeing it
you're gonna be dead
right I don't know why
I'm writing about like this
definitely ready to go like that
you don't apologize I don't even know
what to say it let's play it
sometimes
fair enough
I've never felt this before my life
okay well you think about it
I think talking can
some therapy can help you out possibly
you do over the phone
I'll get your phone you can talk to
somebody I just really wanna like
lose my life from breaking my life you
know what I mean not like are you
enjoying this life
actually yes the parts of it where I'm
like completely [__]
I don't think they should show you know
what I mean it's a [__] show
the world's the best thing you buy
Rebecca huh the world is passing you by
there's so many things you could be
doing you could be involved in I know in
the world in life so can I
well you might have to make some changes
the drug use is pretty out of control
and the key to that is probably the
therapy that I'm talking about
the drug use what was it
laughs
it's not like a matter of
technology Vibes you know what I mean
like
profanities just like that you know
I don't know
I know I do and I know I know better I
can see her you know
I mean all I can see is that this life
that you're living right now what we're
looking at is not going to lead to
anything good
you're not going to get any opportunity
with your with whatever you want to do
nothing's going to come your way
with this with what you're doing right
now
I mean
so maybe some therapy you talk things
out you figure out what's at the bottom
of all this things I can still fix
things
you can fix them by yourself
wow my team and stuff I don't know I
don't know how to put up
[__]
you're like
anyone can be
fixed as I thought you know
I just saw a dollar actually in real
life I don't know
what you think about it
and don't buy any more Fentanyl
that's what we want thank you
[Music]
I feel sick huh you feeling sick
huh
can I put this over your shoulder yeah
sure yeah and then I can attach this
here I am
I know
oh Rebecca oh my God
what are you doing now what are you up
to
I don't know
so last time we spoke you said something
about
you might be deported yeah yeah I mean
it's just immigration
I can do it I know I just I never filed
for residency here so you know like I
fought for green card so yeah
how did this how did you find out that
they're possibly going to deport you
um and also like I stopped for something
and he told me anyway
I'm sorry huh how did you find this out
and officers stopped me like I was like
like I'm assuming her and then you told
me that I was gonna be Departed
you know what the solution to that is
huh we talked about this you know what
the solution to that is yeah it's a
lawyer yeah yeah but a lawyer's not
going to take you
because you're so obviously a drug fiend
and you won't quit
hey Rebecca what do you want to do with
your life
how about that one I don't know
what do you want to do with your life
I really want to get into fashion but
I'm worried that my reputation with this
uh misdemeanor in town yeah Phil's
homelessness has been a complete
detraction
from the media I mean you're what
sometimes there's a clean my act up yeah
no if you cleaned your act up I bet you
a lot of doors would open for you I know
yeah
[Music]
what do you think you're so
self-destructive
and pardon me that just I don't know
like chaos like I um
[Music]
clearly you're
highly intelligent
creative as can be
talented funny smart you've got all
these great qualities but you just love
to [__] yourself up that's true
they're gonna screwing myself up right
there
[Applause]
what do you think that's all about
I know Muhammad I guess I don't know
burning [__] piece of garbage yeah
I'm sorry I'm a burning piece of glass
at this point
you're a burning piece of garbage yeah
what did you what do you think you don't
want better for yourself huh why do you
think you don't want better for yourself
I do want butter for myself no I don't
think I don't
you're walking around shoeless tell me
you want a lawyer
I know we can dress you up but you're
still going to behave like a drug fiend
when you're in there in court or meeting
with a lawyer or whatever I
mm-hmm
I'm just trying to help you out I know
yeah I'm not saying I'm not accepting
your help
if I continue giving you money I know
what that's going to get spent on
fire walk with me
I'm sorry fire walk with me what does
that mean
hi Mark can I change who there's a movie
that came out it was a different movie
firewall with me
I'm not trying to keep one alive but you
know please explain how please explain
like one of my favorite David Lynch
movies it's called fire walk with me
remember your mulhan drive okay yeah
anyway
the prequel to Laura Palmer's cow
because I like this right firewalk with
me
the horns are screwed up way should I
cut my [__] and then there you go
[Music]
I would love to help you out but I just
I'm imagining taking you into meet a
lawyer yeah and you're high as a [__]
kite or you don't even show up that's
more likely but let's say you did show
up on time clock I kind of have to
report my new thing I've been in court
before you don't do anything you have to
do
that's true I've been very negligent
certain responsibility of lately yes
like my confidence in you doing the
right thing yeah is very very low
it is with this little shot there I
don't know and you keep telling me Oh
you're gonna do better you're going to
do better but like just show me that
you're going to do better I know yeah
he's shaving a shower like complete
cosmetic makeover
I'll get your room I'll get you a
roommates we'll take a shower
I had a cosmetic makeover but you know
you're a handful
definitely not
if you're doing your phone today
I can get you I'll try to get your phone
today too yeah
so you'll lose it tonight
turn off those up time
how's your ear huh how's your ear
it's a little better honestly it's kind
of stuffed up still
yeah
it keeps it honestly because a lot of
people
very interesting
to drown out the haters as they say
you're so filthy you're so filthy I know
I definitely need a shower
covering oil flick you know what I mean
yeah you smell too
I smell attack I need new clothes I need
a shower
shave
plate makeover
you think there's anything that would
motivate you to start
living a
boring square life like the rest of us
because I remember boys Square lives
that's true I'm trying to get out of it
that's what I'm trying to motivate here
because you look at you're having so
much fun
I wanted another fun yeah I'm getting
really bored enough honestly I'm ready
for like the next phase of my life I
feel happy
if you continue from this studio to
Earth that's what I would do
I'm sorry I feel an apartment or a
college or something I really want a job
in fashion I just shave and
do you understand as an employer
If an employer was saying oh maybe maybe
we'd hire this Rebecca person and so
they watch you and you're you're
writhing in some drug-induced craziness
what kind of things can we talk about
because we're going around in circles
you're not going to stop putting people
thought no you're not going to put down
the drugs
and you're going to get deported
going back to Egypt which sounds like a
death sentence for a gay gay young man
well I should probably kill myself but
you know I bargain with the government
so I gotta please you think that would
be motivation to maybe
say hey let's talk about going to a
rehab or something
and you're just you're just not on board
with that
yeah
I'm sorry
I don't even know what to talk about
anymore why I don't even know what to
talk about with you anymore because it's
like
if I give you money
you're gonna get high
and then and then your your problems
just
they increase
you're more likely to get deported
yeah
oh God but if you got
clean straight whatever you want to call
it
then a lawyer might take your case and
then your immigration problems might get
solved oh my God whoever there's a
shower and a phone and room you don't
ask for about all right
I'll get your phone in a room and let
you relax for a bit
okay